I don't think it's a case of really
looking for things more kind of being
inspired or excited by the unexpected
actually half the time I find myself
reminding myself of the importance of
keeping an open mind and being really
scared by the prospect of playing
certain types of roles and and surprised
by my desire to face those challenges
I've learnt a lot about preparation over
the years and actually it's so important
to let the preparation go because you
know you can get stuck in this little
sort of tunnel all of your own beetling
away at home and preparing who you think
the character is but the reality is you
have to leave so many sort of blank
spaces for other people to fill by way
of the director and the other actors and
the things that they think and also what
they are bringing to the project through
the roles that they're playing or what
the director has to say if I am playing
a role in the film that is an adaptation
of a book I would always read the book
unless I had been specifically asked not
to by the director but often for me I
find that incredibly useful and I will
always find myself referring back to the
book almost obsessively actually it sort
of becomes my armor my friend
particularly in the case of
Revolutionary Road and the reader both
of those films I remember really I just
would scour the book for pieces of
information that surely the writer
hadn't found or surely the director
hadn't seen and I always really enjoyed
that you know there are challenges in
every single day the biggest one to be
honest with you I think is being able to
stay focused because you can rehearse
and you can plan everything and you can
think you have a you know a framework
that you want to stick with or a few
ideas that you want to remember to keep
in your back pocket and sometimes the
craziness of an on-set environment can
be so intense that you can find yourself
forgetting all of those things that you
plan so actually really really staying
focused and knowing that it's okay to
kind of take yourself off into a quiet
corner and just remember what it was he
who had set out to do and also just
being very accepting of everyone
really because actors can be quite weird
and you know they all have their sort of
tics and ways and
it's you know it's such a privilege to
see how odd everyone is but at the same
time it can really affect your day and
how you're playing a role if you allow
yourself to be caught up in someone
else's stuff or someone else's process
and so just being accepting and sort of
enjoying them for everything that they
are one thing that's always helped me is
really never judging other people
there's always going to be something
that they'll land on in the end and
often we all just have to go through a
bunch of silly stuff first in order to
get to that place and you know that
doesn't happen unless you just let it
you know just because I've had a lot of
experience it certainly doesn't mean
that there are certain things that I'm
really getting right or or or nailing I
mean I would almost hope the opposite
because I want to always be finding new
ways of being able to collaborate and
being able to be included and involved
and excited and passionate the
experience of making a film you know can
often be really very very hard and it
can you know can leave one sort of
feeling okay I'm okay with the fact that
that's over now and then lo and behold
you know the thing will come out and it
will be incredibly fantastic even more
than you could possibly have expected so
throughout my life that has always been
the case every filming experience is
very very different to the finished
product with possibly with the exception
of Sense and Sensibility which was just
absolutely glorious in every respect to
make and completely glorious to watch
and still is for me to this day another
question that I'm often asked is you
know could you help me in any way or
could you and it's a funny thing because
actors can't really help other actors
and I find that quite frustrating
because I wish I could you know because
I'm sure there are so many actors out
there who would give their right arm
just to be in one scene of a film with
no lines I think what I would honestly
say to people starting out you know it
is difficult it is definitely a hard job
to do and you do have to keep working at
it you do have to keep practicing things
you have to allow yourself to make
mistakes you know make them rehearse in
your bedroom try not to look in the
mirror too much because then you can you
rehearse a scene in front of a mirror
and you like the way you've said
something or done something and all you
will do is keep picturing yourself doing
it the way you liked rather than being
completely present in the moment no
looking in mirrors that's not good you
have to keep at it you do and if it is
the thing that you really believe you
want to do with your life
you will get there you just have to keep
going and keep going and keep going and
keep yourself busy you know don't wait
for the phone to ring you know fill your
life in other areas because the more you
enrich your life the more enriched your
be as an actor and as a person and
you'll be able to bring much more to
each role that you hopefully will get
the chance to play I got into a lot of
research with a foe I did called
Dangerous Method and then I didn't
actually all around that period it was
very very research heavy so it would be
whatever the thing was based on and then
I'd go off on a tangent and read just
absolutely everything I went to
university I started English I'm Epstein
Frye Hugh Laurie Robbie Coltrane Ben
Elton we all did comedy together sketch
comedy for two years after I left
University at the very least I did my
own sketch show I did musical theatre I
did mime I did all sorts of stuff I
didn't act until I was 27 years old